in march 2018 sergei skripal and his
daughter yulia were poisoned with a
military-grade nerve agent of a type
developed by russia
commonly known as novacek
two police officers from wiltshire
police involved in searching the victims
homes were also poisoned with the same
agent
in july 2018 a further two members of
the public were found unwell in amesbury
both of whom had been exposed to
novichok
and tragically one of them died and that
was dawn sturges
an inquest into her death is ongoing
and i know that the thoughts of the
whole house will be with the loved ones
of dawn today
mr speaker
this house has profound differences with
russia
by annexing crimea in 2014
igniting the flames of conflict in
eastern ukraine and threatening western
democracies including by interfering in
their elections
russia has challenged the fundamental
basis of international order
although attacks like this are uncommon
it is not the first time russia has
committed a brazen attack in the uk
today the european court of human rights
has ruled that russia was responsible
for the assassination of alexander
lipvienko
this supports the findings of the
independent litvinenko inquiry
however as the then government made
clear in 2018
and desire to reiterate today
we will not tolerate such malign
activity here in the uk
the united kingdom under successive
governments has responded with strength
and determination
as my right honourable friend the member
for maidenhead then prime minister
announced in 2018
250 detectives were involved in the
salisbury murder investigation
working around the clock to discover who
was responsible
on the 5th of september 28 2018
the independent director of public
prosecutions announced that there was
sufficient evidence to bring charges
against two russian nationals for
conspiracy to murder sergey skripal
the attempted murder of sergey skripal
yulia skripal and nick bailey causing
grievous bodily harm with intent to
yulia skripal and nick bailey
and possession
and use of a chemical weapon contrary to
the chemical weapons act
1996
two russian nationals
were known as alexandra petrov and
ruslan boschevoc
but the police believed these to be
aliases
the then prime minister announced that
the government had concluded the two men
were members of the russian military
intelligence service the gru
and that the operation was almost
certainly approved outside the gru at a
senior level of russian state
i want to recognize mr speaker the
exemplary work of our emergency services
our intelligence agencies armed forces
and law enforcement staff who led the
initial response of this despicable
attack
i also pay tribute to the ongoing work
to bring the perpetrators of this
outrageous attack to justice
we will not let this go
as deputy assistant commissioner dean
hayden has said
this investigation has been
extraordinary complex
and our country is fortunate that so
many brave people do such outstanding
work to keep us safe
as a result of these efforts the police
can now evidence that alexandra petrov
and ruslan boshioff
are aliases for alexandra mishkin and
anatol chepig
and that both are members of the gru
the cps has now authorized charges
against a third individual
known as sergey ferettov
and ct policing investigation identified
that fedotov entered the uk on a flight
from moscow to london heathrow and
stayed at a hotel in central london
between the 2nd and the 4th of march
2018 before returning to moscow
while in the uk
he met with petrov and boshiov
on more than one occasion in central
london the ct policing investigation
has identified and established that
federtop is in fact dennis sergey and he
is also a member of the gru
and that all three individuals
previously worked together for the gru
as part of additional operations
outside of russia
all three men are now wanted by uk
police
arrest warrants are in place for all
three
the police have applied for an interpol
notice against veritof
mirroring those already in place against
the other two suspects
russia has repeatedly refused to allow
its nationals to stand trial overseas
this was also the case following the
murder of alexander litvinenko
when a uk extradition request was
refused
this is only added to the heartache of
those hurt by these attacks
and mr speaker inevitably further damage
our relations with russia
as was made clear in 2018
should any of these individuals ever
travel outside russia
we will work with our international
partners and take every possible step to
detain them and extradite them to face
justice
mr speaker after the attack in salisbury
my right honourable friends the members
from maidenhead and oxbridge in south
reislip put in place the toughest
measures the uk has levied against any
other state for more than 30 years
comprising of diplomatic legislative and
economic measures
we will continue to take robust steps to
counter the threat
posed by the russian state
and in 2018
23 undeclared russian intelligence
officers were immediately expelled from
the uk
in solidarity
28 other countries and nato joined us
resulting in the largest collective
expulsion ever of over 150 russian
intelligence officers
this fundamentally degraded russian
intelligence capability for years to
come
the government will continue to provide
the security services and law
enforcement agencies with all the
additional tools they need to deal with
the full range of state threats which
continue to evolve
in direct response to the salisbury
attack we introduce new powers to enable
the police to stop question search and
detain individuals at the uk border to
determine whether they are a spy or
otherwise involved in hostile activity
these vital powers are already helping
the security services and law
enforcement agencies to protect the uk
from very real and serious threats posed
by states who seek to undermine and
destabilize our country
in july 2020 we published a full and
comprehensive response to parliament's
intelligence and security committees
russia report this address point by
point all the key themes and
recommendations raised by the committee
but we are going even further
and have committed to
introducing new legislation to counter
state threats to protect the united
kingdom
earlier this summer we held a public
consultation on the government's
proposals to improve our ability
to detect respond to and prevent state
threats keep our citizens safe and
protect sensitive data and intellectual
property
responses to that consultation are
currently being considered and we will
return with comprehensive legislation
another crucial strand of combat in this
work is combating illicit finance
squeezing out the dirty money and money
launderers out of the uk
to secure our global prosperity is our
priority
we're at the forefront of the
international fight against illicit
finance combating the threat from source
to destination
we have introduced a new global human
rights sanctions regime and global
anti-corruption sanctions regime
and the national crime agency continues
to lead the uk's effort
to bring the full power of law
enforcement to bear against
serious criminals corrupted leaves
and their assets
including through increased checks on
private flights customs and freight
travel
in july and september 2020 working in
tandem with the eu
we announced sanctions against the
russian intelligence services for cyber
attacks against the uk
and her allies
we have also taken robust action in
response to the poisoning and attempted
murder of alexey navain navalny
enforcing
asset freezes and travel bans against 13
individuals and a russian research
institute involved in the case
the government will continue to respond
extremely robustly to the enduring and
significant threat from the russian
state
we continue to make huge strides to
counter this threat and to increase our
resilience and that of our allies to
russian malign activity
mr speaker we respect the people of
russia but we will do
whatever it takes
everything it will take to keep our
country safe
we will work actively to deter defend
against the full spectrum of threats
emanating from russia until relations
with its government improves
mr speaker i'd like to end by paying
tribute to the resilience of the people
of salisbury
who suffered a sickening and despicable
act in their community
and to the people of amesbury
who lost one of their own in the most
dreadful of circumstances
our government will be relentless in our
pursuit of justice for the victims of
these attacks and continue to do
whatever is necessary to keep our people
safe i commend this statement to the
house